so we have like this perfect storm of
conspiracies conspiracism and conspiracy
theories that are swirling around 5g
mobile connectivity and it is now
melding with the coronavirus to create
some amazing conspiracy theories so let
me catch you up on five G five g's the
fifth generation as the name suggests
wireless communication technology and it
is the potential really to be a game
changer the download speeds for 5g or
one to two in the ones that do gigabit
range depending on which country we're
looking at that is a level of throughput
that could revolutionize what's possible
with mobile phones and mobile devices
applications connectivity really could
be a major game changer
now before coronavirus 5g has been one
of the fastest growing conspiracy
theories including health-related
conspiracy theories as well as sort of
government surveillance type stuff the
anti 5g activists have alleged on social
media and in various forums and blogs
that 5g can cause infertility it can
cause cancer it can cause autism
Alzheimer's the death of birds sleep
disruption hypoxia just about everything
in between
there is no solid evidence that mobile
communications networks harm human
health there's a seven-year study on
this that has found no risks associated
with the technology that is used in 5g
communications and the old conspiracy
theories more generally about radio wave
radiation are also being revived around
5g despite those also having been
extensively researched and debunked over
the last many decades so then we've got
the 5g stuff in comes corona virus like
a like a rocket and a whole new slate of
conspiracy theories argue that the two
are connected so I'll tell you about how
this works
one of the theories is the real reason
for 5g with its fast download speeds is
to enable mass live surveillance to in
detail know exactly what every person on
earth is doing maybe governments are
doing it maybe shadowy organizations are
doing it you combine this with
coronavirus
and it gets very very crazy so one idea
is coronavirus originated in China China
has recently turned on some 5g networks
so clearly the two are connected in some
way now of course there's no reason to
actually think that but one thing that's
important to understand is that there
are two types of 5g signals there's
what's called millimeter wave and then
there's the sub 6 gigahertz 5g signals
the millimeter wave are the new ones the
sub 6 gigahertz ones are also what are
used for 4G that's what's been turned on
in China so even at its face it's
ridiculous but when you actually look at
the details it doesn't make any sense
the 5g stuff turned on in China is the
same as the 4G stuff just faster that's
been around for a long time another
version of the 5g coronavirus conspiracy
suggests that the virus itself was
released deliberately as a pretext to
get people to stay inside their homes so
that vast secret installations of 5g
networks could be done without people
noticing it this one's aggressively dumb
because it's not a secret that 5g is
being rolled out and then more generally
there are all sorts of kind of
irresponsible baseless allegations like
for example those who are using 5g for
nefarious means also want forced
vaccinations and what better pretext for
forced vaccinations then coronavirus it
makes perfect sense now we could take
any one of these and analyze it for a
long time I'm just giving you some
examples here's one other one that's
maybe my favorite this theory suggests
that the symptoms of corona virus are
really not the symptoms of corona virus
they're the symptoms of hypoxia the lack
of oxygen which they say can be caused
by 5g signals themselves this includes
shortness of breath headache dizziness
dry cough seizures and fainting doesn't
explain the fever but the idea is people
don't really have corona virus they have
slowly developed hypoxia and are
suffocating from the 5g signals that's
probably enough but you now get a sense
of why and how quickly
these things become weaponized in
increasingly dangerous ways